JMS has dropped the first images of the
new Babylon 5 animated movie and they
look pretty cool welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV the movie channel
[Music]
so I'm outside in this beautiful sunny
day just you know catching some rays
when I checked jms's Twitter feed as I
regularly do to realize that he's
actually dropped some of the first
images for the new Babylon 5 animated
movie one of the things I was excited
about was to see zathras in it azithras
however he wants whichever brother it is
we don't know zathras if you don't know
was a character that was very popular in
original Babylon 5 movies he was the
caretaker of the Greek machine a machine
that could actually create and expand
temporal vortices Babylon 4 got sucked
into one of those temporal vortices and
transported back in time like a thousand
years to actually be a central point for
the ancient conflict back then between
the shadows and the roll-ons and
everybody bloody else
so that thrust being in this is quite
exciting because we know that the
Babylon 5 story is a time travel story
we know that it's about Sheridan getting
trapped in time and having to travel
through several different time frames
and even different universes and his
journeys to try to get back home hence
the title of the animated movie
so these images are kind of exciting and
gives us a little bit of a hint a little
bit more information about the plot that
we can expect also if this animation
style seems a little bit familiar to you
it's because this is made by Warner
Brothers and Warner Brothers Animation
Studios was actually merged in 2022 with
the Cartoon Network Studios so this is
the kind of Animation style we've become
used to in the last few years from them
it actually looks a lot like a lot of
the Batman movies that have come out
so what can we expect and what are we
looking forward to with Babylon 5 over
the next few months well we know that
this is going to come out at some point
in the summer
now we also know that we can expect the
trailer this week some point he did say
mid-june so hopefully that's going to be
anytime soon as you think these images
being released now is probably a little
bit of a teaser and we're going to hit
the trailer at some point in the next
seven to ten days
now I am told that this is actually
going to be available on DVD and Blu-ray
and 4K and all that when it is released
it's also then going to appear on lots
of those Cinema streaming places so over
here in the UK it'll probably be on Sky
Cinema and it'll be on lots of other
places like Amazon you'll be able to
rent it for behind the paywall though
initially and then eventually it will
end up on HBO or Max or whatever the
hell it's called this week
so that is what we can look forward to
this should be out in the next few weeks
and the trailer should be very exciting
to see very soon and I will be with you
as soon as it does hit to tell you
exactly what I think but let's be honest
this looks pretty cool it's got a 12a
rating here in the UK and a PG-13 in the
United States we know that there's going
to be some realistic injury Etc and you
know some shooting going on from the um
over here in the UK when they get a PJ
rating from the CBBC thing that they um
actually give you a little bit of a
rundown of what the show is like as well
so we know a few little details but
nothing too excited
tell me what you think for one what's
the weather like over there because God
is glorious here in the UK two what do
you actually think about the style of
the animation because I have seen some
people saying that they're not overly
impressed it's too simplistic they'd
have liked something maybe a little bit
different maybe a bit more Manga style
which I actually think this looks like
that but you know this to me looks like
a lot of the stuff the Cartoon Network
have done in the last few years so I'm
not really surprised by it but what do
you think get to the comments if you're
honor to the channel don't forget to
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of any videos also
you can go to patreon.com most of our
new videos Premiere first
as always guys please stay safe stay
safe in the sun use suntan lotion good
for you and I'll see you next time
[Music]